buongiorno lei qua per l'appartamento in
affitto
se allora percorre terze le dico che ci
sono già due proposte che la proprietà
sta valutando quindi io gliela faccio
vedere ma non si faccia illusioni e ora
appartamento di 33 metri quadri super
calpestabili appena ristrutturato no a
soffitto con travi in legno pericolante
dell'ottocento e non è stato toccato
come ristrutturazione totale siete della
sostituzione delle lampadine ad olio con
quelle elettriche raggiunta dei comini
sotto le sedie per non recare il parquet
completamente rialzato come può notare
l'appartamento e composto da pezzi unici
risalenti al primo secolo avanti cristo
no immobili rimangono anche perché danno
quel quid in più l'appartamento che come
può notare è un appartamento
assolutamente di rappresentanza per
questo motivo cerchiamo persone super
referenziate contratto sander quattro
più quattro parlamentari ci fatto sei
mesi la gestione bancaria e nel suo caso
immagino anche poteva solo a casa dei
suoi genitori lei di cosa si occupa no
nel senso credo proposte che abbiamo
sono di un notaio e una di un calciatore
di serie a matt né per stop dreaming ci
si senta pure io rimango qui a chiudere
le finestre scusi gentilmente si può
firmare foglio della visita grazie mille